there's normally an alarm turned on here
but things we've been in and out so much
so down here are CBL
it's quite noisy in here so we go
somewhere else tell me what it is you've
been doing on this particular project
it's I'm a technician here my official
job title is IT systems engineer but I
do a lot of different things within the
school everything from sort of Health
and Safety all the way through to
designing GPU complete computing
clusters apparently yes so I'm actually
a researcher here I shouldn't be looking
after computers probably but I enjoy it
and so yeah I like to look after the
software installed on these machines and
play around a little bit with the
networking side and and also some of the
hardware I think Joe is the real hot one
guy I believe you guys need guys to talk
to about Beast and its siblings yeah
we've seen beast in the password
cracking video now this is worse an SSH
terminal but this is beef things have
moved on since though what's going on
now right now we have three generations
of GPU computing machines in the school
beast and rogue are the first generation
of those machines is the naming regime
based on anything specific definitely
x-men but I know nothing about it I ask
people what they want to name them and
we have votes or something like that so
yeah the last few have been voted on
honey but but yeah before that was a bit
more autocratic and we just chose the
shortest names that we could find in the
x-men character list on Wikipedia yeah
were there well over a hundred
characters that we could choose from at
the moment as far as I remember that
we've got quite a few spare we're in the
computer vision lab and there's probably
I don't know 13th of 20 people who are
actively doing research here in deep
learning so there's definitely a need
for some kind of computing power here
and in many research groups they might
just you know install a couple of GPUs
and in everybody's workstation the
problem with that is that many people
don't need that you've you all the time
and when they need more than one or two
TP use what do you do you it may make
sense to share these resources in sort
of a cluster we originally started off
designing this emphasis
structuring way that was quite homebrew
if you like we wanted to prove to the
research group that this kind of
hardware could produce good results have
you know impactful results if you like
and so we built the first two
generations of machines wasn't at room
the first generation of beast and
regular based off kind of a work station
platform x99 single processor with four
GPUs maximum we then moved on to a dual
processor platform the Intel Xeon based
there are also 4 DP journals before some
of them got free some four depending on
the configuration make this a couple of
them were limited by their cases weren't
they yeah so that was deadpool which is
mike's machine and we changed the case
for that just so we could fit an extra
GPU we started off with as joe said
earlier you know just beast and rogue
they became very popular they were
utilized almost continuously over time
obviously deep learning has become much
more popular you're hearing about in the
news almost every week more more more of
the researchers in the lab more of the
PhD students are moving towards deep
learning from traditional computer
vision methods so the requirement for
hardware has increased significantly we
started off with just these two machines
and as we've grown it's become almost
impossible to manage and to decide which
machine to use we've entered more of a
cluster state now so we have a login
node which you login to submit your jobs
from there the scheduler decides which
machine your job should be run on
depending on what it requires in terms
of number of GPUs perhaps memory even
you can have constraints such as does it
have 10 gigabit networking for example
so yeah works in a very similar way to a
traditional HPC system we tried a couple
of other
methods of scheduling GPUs like being
one of them yeah kind of informal
methods they didn't really work out so
we had to we had you know there was some
kind of awkwardness let's say around
around those discussions so we had to
come up with a system that was fairer
and yeah so Aaron had a look into some
of the some of the options and he
settled on slam didn't usually no real
reason for using slam it seems to have
very nice support in terms of GPU
constraints so you can assign a GPU to a
user nobody else can touch it for the
time that the job is allocated to the
for the GPU I think similar things are
possible in older systems such as PBS
which was used on the old university HPC
that we have here but slurm seems to be
the the way that this sort of technology
is moving slow is an open source
scheduling system it's named after the
drink and Futurama I can't remember what
it stands for I think they might have
done kind of a backronym thing and named
it afterwards slow and basically decides
when your job can run so there's a queue
when you submit a job it goes into this
queue as the resources become available
which hopefully is almost immediately
because we have limitations on how many
how much resources each user can use the
problem of course with centralizing like
you people
the login is that you also need to
somehow centralize the storage so at the
moment we still actually have the SSDs
installed in each machine there's we
call them DP 1 DB 2 DP 3 etc and there's
anywhere between 1 & 3 of those in each
GPU node but when you're training a
convolutional neural network you need to
be loading your data quickly and you
need to load it many times basically
typically we would decide which machine
we wanted to use and log into that
because we know that our data stored
there problems with this is that you end
up duplicating your copy your data
across multiple machines sometimes the
machine that you want to use is just
busy so you have to use another one so
you copy the data across so you're
wasting space
and it's just annoying to deal with so
if you can centralize this storage for
training your networks you don't have to
worry about you know which machine
should I because I'm just going to log
into one machine and they will figure
out where it should run and you know the
data is all stored in the same place now
obviously when we had the previous
machines they all had their own previous
as individual SSDs and you know you have
the standard SATA 3 speeds of 6 gigabits
per second to each one of those if
you're trying to centralize that you
need something which can handle roughly
the same performance as all of these
combined you're never going to get there
but you can try and get somewhere close
to it so we're using a pretty decent
file system called ZFS it has very
feature for one of the nicest things in
our use case is that it has a caching
layer so for our cache we're using SSDs
this is Wolverine and then attached to
that is an external j-bot so this stands
for just a bunch of disks basically
there's one two three four five six
seven this J board is attached to
Wolverine via a it's called SAS what
does a serial Attached go see that's the
one serial Attached cosy per channel of
SAS 3 you get 12 gigabits per second the
disks themselves can't handle 12
gigabits per second so this j body spend
half the you have database storage over
here and then home directories as we're
training network this part of the
storage is being read from continuously
so when you're training you might have a
data set of maybe a hundred thousand
images you read them all once and during
that time you're learning parameters for
a network but then you do that again and
again you'd like a hundred times
basically so you read the same data a
hundred times so you don't want to
access disks a hundred times it's really
slow so as the data is being read from
DP it's being copied onto the SSDs
installed into this machine and these
are 4 terabyte each i'm reading from an
SSD you know much faster than spinning
disks is that caching handled by the
filesystem or do you have to write
software to do the cache
so ZFS handles the caching automatically
it uses actually it's called adaptive
replacement cache and it uses two
metrics that the sidewall should be
cached what was most recently accessed
and what's most frequently accessed and
you try to balance this so it's 50/50
for each of them on our data base
storage we have a cache hit rate of
about sixty to seventy-five percent
depending on how jobs are starting which
means that you know 60 to 70 percent of
the time we're not going to disk and
waiting for a you know platter to spread
around we can just read the straight
away from the SSD these all configured
into a single is called a raids said too
and that means that you could lose any
two of these so you could lose this one
or this one
the problem with the reside two is that
it limits the number of operation per
second that you can have and that's why
we're using it for home storage with DB
we actually split this again into two
and this is one raids z1 and this is
another raid one and these are striped
together to get the same amount of
storage as home but much faster so you
can handle many more operations per
second what it means though is that if
you were to lose this disk in this disk
you've lost all of this similarly if you
lost this disk or this this then you've
also lost all of the data the only thing
it can do is you could lose maybe one on
this side and one on this side this
obviously doesn't sound good but all you
have to remember is that these databases
are generally downloaded off the web and
we have different file servers for
storing stuff on a more permanent basis
ZFS has really nice it's called send
receive you can do block level transfers
of an entire data set very quickly so
you don't think of them as files you
just think of them as copying the blocks
from disk to it to another server so ZFS
gives lots of options for backups we've
yet to implement them but we're still
kind of transitioning over to this new
storage so there are two layers of
caching there's the l1 Ock and LT walks
there's a level one level two when you
first read a file it will initially be
cached into memory because it has to go
through the CPU anyway to go out of the
network but this is kind of quickly
written over especially when you're
handling
large amounts of traffic so the next
level is level level two so these are
written to the SSD this doesn't happen
as you read the data but you know when
it thinks that it's you know this files
being accessed a lot which is probably
in terms of training at CNN after the
second or third epoch so one epoch is
once you've seen all of the data at once
you know and that's made a like
iteration the way you might pass
anywhere between one and like 30 or even
more samples through the network and
then ya get the parameters what does the
interface to all of this look like for
the user is it just is a command line
thing or is there a GUI sourcing or yeah
so you submit jobs using a command
called S batch and when you submit your
job you specify what you want to run in
basically a shell script and in the
shell script you define how many GPUs
you want in particular but optionally
also how much memory you require and how
many CPU cores you need is it allow you
to come back and say no no you're asking
for too much I can't do yes so one of
the things that can happen is if you ask
for too many GPUs even more than you're
allowed or more than is available it
will just sit in the queue either until
your quota is increased or we buy a new
GP machine with more dps so you're
sitting on a machine in your lab or
whatever and you need to get a job done
what happens talk us through it
well so the user will log in to the to
the master node I suppose you call it
and submit their job with s batch that
would then be picked up and distributed
to the appropriate compute node by the
software it's all kind of automatic and
happens under the hood so it's
abstracted away from the user so that
really any knowledge of what's going on
required so we have log and node this is
called Xavier we have several compute
nodes so this is like bistro gamba etc
and then the storage over here exhale
so here's a user his or her computer and
they will login to Xavier via I say
Xavier joseph's xavier login via ssh and
they submit their job when Xavier is
ready it tells a particular compute
nodes that you know I want you to run
this job with this many GPUs etc as this
job is running it needs to access
storage in some house so this goes over
a separate Network that's why I'm using
a different color this will bounce back
and forth with packets of data until the
job eventually finishes and the result
is sent back to Xavier and then back to
the user so this green is tan gink
and then this is the standard university
won't take a bit of a second network and
ten gigabit is enough for those storage
needs that you were saying it before
that not exactly so one of the things we
have to do is on the file server to the
switch we actually have two links and
then to the GPU machines we have one
link to each one so these are GP
machines and this is the file server and
the way this works is that this is
called a lag link aggregation it uses
something called LACP which is the link
aggregation control protocol and that
protocol decides while communicating
with the switch exactly what kind of
load balancing it should do and it
decides you know I'm going to use link 1
or link 2 and then add a switch it's it
doesn't matter it kind of you know it
only has one link to a particular TP
notes so it just goes out of that one
the biggest problem so far I've been the
network drivers the 10 gig of Ethernet
cards you had to upgrade it on all
machines and on certain machines even
disabled like this kind of
second-generation machines we had to
disable power management for the PCI bus
yeah through through our configuration
management software we tend to maintain
a fairly static configuration on all of
the machines to make things as easy as
possible to troubleshoot if necessary
and to to upgrade and so on and just to
maintain and administer them in general
but yeah we've had to do a few
out-of-band
patches kernel patches and some other
driver installations in order
determine the most reliable
configuration which we then have rolled
out to the remaining machines so yeah a
thing with is it's stable now and a bit
of a learning curve yeah absolutely
we've had to learn on our feet and try
not to disrupt the critical research
applications that happening but my own
include yeah but now hasn't been too
much grumbling over over few little
hiccups and yeah like say it's all
hopefully plain sailing from here on out
what's um what's the OS would it be
something people have recognized that's
running on these yes CentOS 7 patched
right yeah so yeah so they're all
running latest kernel versions and they
actually off yeah the fall so those
running FreeBSD which might be an
unusual choice for most people but I'm
gonna get so much slack in the comments
for this but I don't trust NFS on Linux
yet so yeah I mean even though it's been
out for what six years as kind of
production-ready status we just felt
that perhaps freebsd was slightly more
mature and a better choice for something
that is underpinning the entire
operation you've got a train for a long
time and let's not let Steve off the
hook come on st over here high value of
- high value of one whatever that means
the interesting thing about this is
we're not performing a classification
little-endian systems so that's why we
call it ng in this it all traces back to
eggs of lilliput in Gulliver's Travels